and here's another thing that we have
similar is is that we don't like our own
genitalia oh yeah you hate your vagina I
hear
I just her vagina is so normal it's
irritatingly normal my vagina is the
only thing that's irrational about me
why what does it look like yeah but it
looks like this yeah no it doesn't it
doesn't
I've never seen one lip go yeah it's
like it and listen I don't the reason I
don't like because I feel like I don't
want to spread other women not liking
their genitalia yeah do you know there
are dudes that specifically like
butterfly wings
is that what it is it sticks out though
it did the lips my labia yeah my labia
are like labia minora they come out
majora right not even that much I'm
telling you as she's so exciting
I didn't look like that though like
three years ago it started shifting
maybe you're getting pummeled down I
have a theory on that are you getting
too much pummeling down there now out of
pop no way yeah
what can you get Regina rejuvenations
oh I would get it I've looked it up I
mean the only thing I'm worried about it
is that it might I would never want
anything to affect my [ __ ] mm-hm
I would because for me I come like so
easily it's kind and which is probably
because my vagina is just like open yeah
so there's no digging for it it's just
like there where are you what are you
thinking are you pretending that you're
thinking right now yeah what do you mean
digging for it no I like your lips like
no the [ __ ] like knowing you're go in
anywhere really it's kind of just like
it's exposed I mean it's it's not out
out yeah
but the tip of it the hood clitoral hood
wait you're you're yours is wearing a
headpiece you know wait you're the
vaginas you have no head pieces oh I
have you have a hood circumciser cavity
hey hood you have a kickin
[Music]